céline qui a parlé là dessus je trouve
ça incroyable parce qu'il ya des gens
ici qui étaient choqués puis qui son
genre torse nu mais qui sont pas choqués
de ce que cette jeune fille fait et tu
sais quoi je trouve super le message que
tu dis avoir de l'ambition mais elle est
où la limite entre l'ambition et le
michaud nage et c'est une question
[Applaudissements]
pas besoin de me régler
avec un rap ou avec chez tous parce que
hier ce que tu m'as fait je n'ai encore
là enfin qu'on me traite de bitche mais
bon passons
un problème très sincèrement et moi je
le bien des gens et tout est rentré dans
entre l'ambition et le michaud n'a
jamais entendu son net rebond tout ce
que tu dis des filles au pénal espèrent
peser j'aimerais entreprises pesant je
fais le test de m qu'est ce que vous
répondez temps de la rapport à tout ça
en fait mais en gros ça veut dire qu'il
est en train de dire que j'ai besoin
d'hommes pour réussir c'est bien sa
mission
non mes excuses à monsieur je ne veux
pas mais tu es qui pour me dire que je
t'aime mais ce que c est l heureux de
postes bh aulas
grosse beach c'est aussi chez l'animal
très bien grosse a dit
chantal rajuste truc du coup ça veut
dire que c'est les âmes qui vont acheter
à les culottes portée de ces les hommes
on dépense
trop faible demande est ce que c'est la
constitution donc je le demande vu que
cette estimation
vu que c'est à destination des hommes
mais qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire les
hommes avec string apparemment tu penses
quoi qui met ses nappes du scion pour
toi
en fait dans le test match non mais là
vraiment défini complètement n'entravera
vraiment j'espère qu'elle est enfin
qu'elle va être gentil pas d'attaqué tu
partes stone age le mr nage et ça
voudrait dire moi mais tu es fou tu
viennes dire mr n'a qu'à destination de
qui ces culottes le cas des rapports la
prostitution
tu vas encore contre contre m sauf
énerve est ce le fut mais cyril qu'est
ce qu'ils vont faire les hommes avec ses
strings avec ça écoutez moi je faire le
marché avait
chez désolé du terme est ce qui motive
plus moi l'un l'autre c'est dommage
baisse pour de là en ce que tu en train
d'insinuer en fait normal alors elle en
train d'insinuer qu'il achève vécu leur
bourse pour bourg se masturber mais ça
veut donc dire des filles les gens qui
regardent des pornos temps donc des
miches honneurs et les laissant les
pointes et des lampes anima c'est ce que
demandent juste derrière avec six autres
études et zetes quand mais qu'est ce que
tu y es gimont ne pas payer les gens
pour tu as tes les gens c'est pour ça
que ça va pas sans l'autre parce que
c'est moi qui le dit mais pas nous
pensons sérieusement qu'est ce qui
montre rc mes lèvres dans la
prostitution est ce qu'elle
perd be mais je comprends ce que enfin
trouve hyper mignonne hyper sympa et
franchement le principe de jeu sort
enfin je l'ambition est et reste la même
et ça c'est trop mignon ça n'a aucun
rapport ecoute-moi la joule mais le vent
un art tu sais quoi par exemple clara
morgane elle vend des strings et c'est
pour les femmes femmes elles la
607 total embrayé sur les autres
avaient choqué percée mais là tu le mets
le string docks cgt
fonds saint jacques sur
l argent ces domaines de minutes chaque
jeu j'ai plus d'arguments à dieu quand
tu entends delphine qui l'a vraiment
définis tu veux tu me fait vraiment peur
je n'ai rien contre le fait de jouer
c'est un métier et tout ça m'étonnait
cette fille qui vend ses culottes portée
si tu veux et de du bain c'est de la
prostitution jeu de marc dont elle ce
site mais on saura où elle se situe on
s'en fout ce que vont faire les mêmes et
que del roser slip ça tout faire pour du
buzz ou tout faire pour d' argent c'est
pas qu'une mission et utiliser son corps
c'est cesser ces sécrétions pour faire
de l'argent qu'elle sait que ce n'est
pas maintenant tu vas me dire que par
landreau sort d'un lycéen on sait très
bien que la prostitution des jeunes la
prostitution
[Musique]
certaines histoires sont des jeunes la
discussion a
fait une heure que vous êtes sur la
morale à cette demoiselle c'est un
personnage où il met des choses en
abracadabrante et mes doigts du
processus entamé mais vous êtes vous
défendre et
quelquefois des raisons pour un
thérapeute être papa elle fait son truc
pour son bois restent à quai [ __ ] à
leurs élèves du chant elle veut la
changer la change équivalent mais si
vous
voulez la changer wifi ça c'est pas bien
tj vraie boîte voiture
les
protégerait c'est des préservatifs et
voilà
on fait attention à ces jeunes filles
pardon city ne tapais ma belle famille
orange qui me dérange mais le premier
pas parce qu'en fait elle bougeait mais
pour en voir vous même vos turpitudes
qui vont sur internet une possible chez
une prostituée bizarre non franchement
je cher que tu retires ça bah c'est une
située dans l'est
c'était de la procession des jeunes ont
dû fermer a dit que c'était une grosse
miche twilight ont su gdgt nous était
pas jeter match mais bon moi ouais tu te
c'est là dit que j'ai deux cuts que
j'étais du mr
s'il vous plaît et la côte d'ivoire du
coup ce pack des maîtres en argent donc
si tout est non alors s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît gilbert n'a pas dit ça
tu as tes mais aussi remis à la pana la
question légitime qui vous dit il faut
il faut entendre ce que vous dites est
plus lent je veux le maintenant je veux
une lamborghini je veux faire la
question de delphine chenal moi je vous
la pose directement jusque vous êtes
prêts à aller voir tout ça voilà c'est
ça la question mais aidé des citoyens
c'est la réponse va répondre quels sont
vos limites l'ethnographe pas d'accord
et l'évolution du processus et non la
religion à rejeter la procédure aussi la
production et fiction là encore la
nudité et la religion